in the light of knowing how paradoxes
can occur in logical systems how
undecidability can occur in logical
systems we found out that the parallel
lines hypothesis for Euclid was
undecidable from the propositions that
he gave
we've equally discovered that with
Bertrand Russell's barber paradox
it's undecidable who should shave the
barber it's paradoxical so we now want
to drive all of that forward and revisit
those paradoxes and undecidability x' in
the context of what if you like the
pioneer of computer science Alan
Matheson Turing what did he do Turing
started his research activity in the mid
1930s and his research field was
mathematical logic his approach to doing
mathematical logic was it just as a dry
set of propositions of the sort that
Frager and Hill but Russell were doing
all those well aware their work of
course and it was very well aware of
girdle's work basically showing that any
system of propositions was necessarily
incomplete but no Turing had this
wonderful idea of inventing almost like
a mechanical machine except it was a
pencil and paper exercise now some of
you who've seen the busy beaver videos
will see Turing machines in action
there's also been a video by my
colleague mark Jago showing you in a
very high-level kind of way but very
effectively
why cheering's halting problem really is
undecidable this pencil and paper
computer using nothing but a paper tape
for data a set of program instructions
and a read/write head that moves that
was sufficient he said quite rightly to
compute anything that could be computed
and it's no good saying well we'll
quantum computers go beyond those not at
the moment
quantum computers at the moment still in
the end end up doing Turing machines
faster and in parallel but there's
nothing radically new about them as yet
who knows what may have
in the long run Turing's famous 1936
paper then was about David Hilbert's a
freedoms problem cheering of course
knowing of girdle's work and having
played around with his turing machines
basically said there's going to be
things here that are undecidable and it
varies very soon occurred to him that an
obvious one to do was the halting
problem is it decidable whether that
program with that data will halt and the
answer is in certain special cases yes
you can but it's a general formula that
says yes or no know that the nuts and
bolts level the busy beaver problem
helps you to understand how this comes
about but at the more philosophical
level if you've seen marc jacobs video
about how that wonderful machine works
if you look at the machine you'll find
that inside it there's a thing called
age what it does is it says give me a
program P give me it's data it's in port
which we'll call I will that P with that
I hold is it generally decidable this is
the magic H machine now what mark then
did which may have baffled some of you
but I want to refer this back now to
what we know about things like barber
paradoxes and so on if you recall the
barb of paradox it says the barber
shaves all those in the village who do
not shave themselves in order to show
that something leads to a paradox and
there is therefore is undecidable it's
got to have that element of not nurse in
it as Bertrand Russell might easily have
said where does the not come in in mark
and Shaun's model the H taking a P
taking an I look at the video and you'll
see they do to bolt on extras at the
rear of that machine and all that those
bolt on extras are doing is reversing
the logic if the inner h has decided
that it does hold and delivers a yes
then the outer machine turns the yes
into spinning around in a loop and not
halting conversely if the inner machine
age says no it doesn't stop I can see it
booping' then the outer machine says oh
I'm going to reverse the logic I'm going
to turn a no into a yes so the outer
machine H+ is basically putting the
element of not Ness and denying at the
back of the H machine and once you've
done that you can model the barber
paradox with the H+ machine just as you
say to ask of the barber make him
reflect on himself should I shave myself
or should I not show myself equally with
the H+ machine you say okay I'm going to
feed myself to myself I'm going to have
the H+ machine with H+ as the program
and H+ is its data import and I've now
got to say do I halt so I'm going to
restate the barber paradox as follows
h+ delivers a halt for all those turing
machines that do not hold themselves so
in other words if the inner h machine
comes back and says yes it holds you say
no when i read a halt we make it spin
but for the ones when it says no it
hasn't stopped it spinning it's going to
come back and say yes it does hold so in
other words the outer add-on is forcing
a halt on you and saying yes I can make
the whole thing hold so if H plus
delivers a halt for all those Turing
machines that do not help hold
themselves then what your machine is it
that causes H+ to hold and as you look
at it you realize oh it's exactly the
same as the barber so fine I think the
only problem with this if you like
philosophical way of doing things and I
felt this very strongly when I finally
sort of got to grips with this stuff
because I had to teach it people is what
sort of system is it which requires you
to drive yourself into a paradox to get
a proof I mean how does this all affect
me as an ordinary computer scientist
writing ordinary programs if you just do
heat calculations involving I don't know
statistics website maintenance weather
prediction and so on fine
you're not going to be bothered by this
but the
word I think is self-referential you get
into difficulties with anything that's
self referential the barber problem is
self referential because it's saying the
barber is a man as well as a barber look
inside the system what happens Bertrand
Russell's paradox is self referential
it's looking inside the set of all sets
during halting problem is self
referential it's getting a machine to
examine other machines so I felt like
swearing a sort of stout oath and saying
I promise I will never write a program
that analyzes other programs thereby I
can avoid trouble but actually if you're
a computer scientist you can't totally
avoid trouble this stuff does come to
bite you because I suddenly started to
think ah
I'm not going to write a program that
analyzes other programs but I'm very
interested in programs that can generate
other programs how can I prove that if I
generate a program and this
conventionally happens with tools called
passage ener ators sometimes called
compiler compilers very similar you give
a program specification to a program and
it generates another program how can you
show that that Froemming you generate
will not run into paradoxes and
undecidability actually if you're not
careful you'll get some nasty results
come out of those and some big shocks if
you're not aware of the fact that
certain things are undecidable I will
eventually get round to showing you an
example of this it's basically down to
just doing simple parse trees I've done
some of these before for things like a
plus B star C sometimes you get into
things where you can have more than one
possible parse tree it's ambiguous and
so you think yourself oh ah
I'm writing a parser I better just do a
quick check on what's been asked of me
just I'll do a quick check to make sure
it's not going to lead to an ambiguous
set of trees no good you could be trying
to compute the uncomputable it may be
very well hidden but you may end up in a
grammar that is so complex that drive
you to endless
layers of recursive investigation to see
if this really is decidable or not it
could get every bit as bad as a common
in a worse case you might say well you
know let's keep it fun out I promise
I'll never give you anything to pass
that's longer than a thousand characters
yeah yeah yeah but that doesn't satisfy
a mathematician it doesn't satisfy a
computer scientist you want general
robust solutions so what actually
happens in the case of parsers is that
the so called passages and as one I hope
to do with you briefly in a future movie
one called yak yet another compiler
compiler it has got the most ingenious
hidden way of stopping you blundering
into undecidability you give it
something that's beyond its powers and
it basically is incapable of knowing
it's beyond this powers it just says
under these circumstances I am going to
do this be warned the parcel I deliver
you in these nasty circumstances may not
be quite the one you expect so there we
are that is an example of undecidability
in action and it's nice to know for the
first time that I'd be able to give you
a concrete example of something where
you do need to beware now many of you
out there of course we say yeah fine
okay so if you're a computer scientist
and if you're writing things that
generate other programs yes you need to
be where need I be as aware as this if
all I'm doing is maintaining a website
nowadays maybe not
have to get less fit before you get more
fit evolutionism plan right so it can't
see that there's this huge hill army
destitute this is dreadful
the barber shaves only those who do not
shave themselves